So our students have been learning about
variables and data types in this lesson.
Particularly about integers and strings.
Are there examples in the apps that
you've worked on of these things?
>> Yes, there are plenty.
So, strings and integers are everywhere.
In Gmail for example, when you first
open your email it tells you how many
unread messages that you have, so
that's a very, very important number.
And we actually have
these very subtle bugs,
that the number might not match exactly
how many unread messages you have.
So.
[CROSSTALK]
>> I've never had encountered
that, have you?
>> That's good.
>> [LAUGH].
>> That you've never encountered that.
So, yeah, but these are, you know,
it's an interesting problem to solve,
because for Gmail,
we actually sync that number first.
Like sync means like,
I'm fetching my data from
the Cloud to my Android device.
So, that data is actually,
that number, is synced separately
from your actual email.
So, they could potentially
go out of sync.
That is one of the very trickier issues.
>> Okay, so we were established that the
number of unread emails is a variable.
It's data type would be.
>> It would be an integer.
It's value is being
calculated across devices.
And it's value is changing based
on the use case of the scenario.
I use it as experience.
>> Yes, exactly.
And another use of integers, so
that's an example of a variable integer,
basically it could change.
Another example is ID's.
So for ID's it's actually very important
that the integer stays the same.
>> So my email ID, particularly.
Okay.
>> Exactly.
So the email ID on the server
that represents that
email needs to be exactly the same
as the ID that's on the client.
Because that's the way
we uniquely identify
this email everywhere
across all your devices.
>> So this is for our conversation
email, not like an email address.
>> Yes, for our conversation, so for
in Gmail for example the whole thread.
So the email thread which has multiple
messages in it, the whole thread we call
a conversation, it has a conversation
>> Oh, okay, I see.
>> And then each message itself
also has its own unique ID.
>> Okay, and each one of these ID's is
stored in a variable who's data type is?
>> Integer again.
>> Okay.
>> Yes
>> How many
emails are going out in a day.
Do you know?
This is a lot of numbers.
>> Yes, I do, I do not know on
top of my head how many emails.
>> I'd imagine that if each message
in a conversation is unique and
each email is unique across
all emails that are going.
>> Yes.
>> That should be a very large number,
right?
>> So that's a very good question.
So instead of int actually for
these we use logs.
>> Okay.
>> Because it's a 64 bit.
>> So then we will never.
[CROSSTALK]
>> So long just gives you more space to
hoard a larger number, right?
That's really the difference
between Inter Long?
Okay.
>> How about any strings?
>> Strings.
>> I'd imagine it's subjective.
A string, or how is that stored?
>> Yeah, everything.
Yeah, subject is a string itself.
>> Okay.
>> And
obviously email addresses are strings.
That's very important.
And almost everything
that you see in any app,
like virtually everything that
has text will be a string.
And I think a good engineer
doesn't have to know everything.
But you really,
you have to be good at like figuring
out like, you know where the answer is.
You can probably look for, there's
a lot of good tutorials out there for,
just have to know how to look for
the right key words.
Search for the right key words.
>> If you also ask people for help.
>> Oh yes,
that is actually very important.
I think almost always I regret
not asking people earlier.
You know I could like try to fix
something, for like a whole day, and
at the end of the day,
said okay, maybe I should have
asked whoever wrote this component.
So yeah, I think reaching out to
people early is definitely valuable,
to save very valuable time.
And also just being more aware of what
other projects are going on at Google.
I think the, or at your own, around you.
I think the really good engineers,
they're not only focus on what they're
doing, but they we have these
things called tech talks at work.
>> Which are available publicly for
people to view,
at least some of them are.
>> Yes.
Some of them are, yes.
So their often know what the latest
technologies are, from these tech talks
or announcements that are sent
to the entire engineering org.
So, just being on top of.
>> And let's go back to the time when
you were actually learning to program.
If you could talk to
the Alice at that time,
what advice would you give her today?
>> Wow.
That's a very interesting question.
I feel like I should have had
more fun with programming.
So, I think the way I
learned to program, and
I think it's very different now, because
I grew up in, originally I'm from China.
So I think it was very
academically focused.
Like, I went to these extracurricular
classes that tlike taught via teacher,
and then we'd get assignments
like you learn to solve them, and
learn to solve this problem.
And I think, looking back,
I wish I had like done
more fun-type projects.
>> Would you make a birthday app?
A birthday app?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah exactly,
like, these type of apps I
think I could learn a lot more.
Because it's not just about
there's one right answer.
But in like doing an app
like that I can learn about
design if its a birthday app.
I learn about different UI
components its not just about,
okay you need to send this
data from here to here.
And then solve it more efficiently.
I think in real life that is what,
you know, engineering is more about.
It's about not just solving
a technical challenge, but
also creating a great product.
>> Sort of like being driven
by your own curiosity.
>> Yes, exactly.
Yes.
>> Well, Cathy and
I want to thank you for your time.
>> You're very welcome.
>> I think our students will benefit
a lot from your perspective.
>> Yeah, okay.